named for the groundbreaking astronomer
the Hubble Space Telescope allows us to
look deep into the universe back in time
and closer to the moment of the Big Bang
but for scientists winding back the
clock to the Big Bang was only the first
step
when people first here by the Big Bang
Theory they say well where did it take
place it took place over there it took
place over there where did it take place
actually it took place everywhere
because the universe itself was
extremely small at that time these are
only some of the most abstract and
difficult concepts there are so here's a
mind bender what came before the Big
Bang the philosophers in ancient times
used to say how could something arise
from nothing and what's amazing to me is
that the laws of physics allow that to
happen
and it means that our whole universe
everything we see everything that
matters to us today could have arisen
out of precisely nothing it's one of the
biggest hurdles to understanding the Big
Bang first you have to buy into the
premise that something was created out
of nothing it's impossible to describe
the moment of creation in human language
all we know is that from what may have
been nothing we go to a state of almost
infinite density and infinite
temperature and infinite violence
understanding how nothing turned into
something maybe the greatest mystery of
our universe
but if you understand that you start to
understand the Big Bang when time and
space began and the great big explosion
created everything